I know nine to five tae-il when de
science guy and I look the role widens
face go on to level Aaron the science
guy
good to see you why does space go on
forever yeah that's a that's a great
question that's a deep question and no
one really knows the actual answer to
that maybe you will be the one who
figures it out but near as we can tell
the farther we look into space farther
it seems to go with that said we can see
that all the stars are moving apart and
so people have figured out that they
must have all been at one place about
thirteen point six billion years ago and
so people can observe light that we
believe is thirteen point six billion
years old but nobody knows what's beyond
that or if it's even if it is even a
meaningful question to ask what's beyond
that like what would the world be like
if there were no world uh it would be
different and so these are deep deep
questions and the people who think about
these questions are called
astrophysicists they study the motion of
stars physics is the study of motion and
Astro has to do with stars so perhaps
you will be an astrophysicist who
figures this out cool question
you